Hello Freak bitches and IPA can
take you for a turn. Like my wife.
This is like here have some odd cause
yeah, I usually come in like if I,
if I get a little bias,
I'll come in you now and she wanted to
hang and I'm out there just just drinking
and staring at a fire and a,
she gave me this IPA called dog fish and
it's 18% alcohol and like three beers
in. I'm like blacked out
because I was just drinking.
I'm like beers and I'm like,
oh three beers now come in. That's
so unnecessary. And it was like,
what do they do that to people?
I don't know. It was like,
it's like spike in some wine. I was
like roofing is, here's the thing.
Like it's you can't, this is one
of my, I had a bit about this,
about my problem and pot gummy bears.
You said one of the problems is it looks
like a regular fucking gummy bear in my
brain thinks, oh I could just fucking
eat the shit out of those gummy bears.
I getting five or 10 of them.
False representation could
just Jack your world.
There's a video I put on Instagram of
Lisa yet. Have you seen that video?
One by one design,
put it up and he's got a,
a video that they took from Joey d as
the Church of what's happening now and
Lisa,
it is literally the physical example
that you would use if someone who's too
high. What's too hot? You like this?
This is too high. Like look at him there.
He's got his eyes closed.
Give me some volume, Jamie.
They're all talking. They're playing
some music and look at him. Look at him.
Look at his eyes. Fade
new now. By the way,
he knew he was supposed
to be at the podcasts.
Not like they woke them up
to do a podcast. He left
the camera on himself too.
Yeah, yeah. I love the camera
at himself and he's just,
he's so paranoid right now.
He's freaking the fuck out.
Fucking throws his head back. He
said, Jesus, I can't do this anymore.
Can Work and can't work with you.
Joey Diaz.
He's just thinking about it now.
Demons,
just waiting for him to close his
eyes and go to sleep. I can't,
I can't give to the demons.
You don't see them over him
just scratching at the ceiling,
just waiting for the lights to turn
out and his eyelids to clothes.
Am I going to go through his
fucking mouth? Penetrate his body?
And I've been that exact guy on
that exact podcast. Ooh, yeah.
Jay gave me the story. I just, I couldn't
handle it, man. He's a different animal.
I love that dude. He's the best, but he's
a different animal. You can eat, you know,
don't, don't try to outdo him
ever. I was just trying to hang,
he was the one that he had the
one he went, he had mercy on me,
which I thought was
incredible cause I'm like, Yo,
let me just grab up another little stars
death. And he's like, no way doc. Yeah,
you're going to fucking
try to be nice to you.
But like what you said about the
gummy bears, it's like, yeah.
It's almost like the false representation
is the thing I don't like more than
the representation itself.
Okay.